Music Hello everybody, it's Joel Blackstock with the Taproot Therapy Collective podcast, and today we're going to be reading an article called Synesthesia, Blending the Senses to Distill the Soul. Now, before we begin our discussion of synesthesia, or we even define it if you don't know what it is, we're going to consider this passage from a book called The Peregrine, which is one of my favorite books. It is a bird watching journal of a naturalist, which sounds boring as hell, but it is beautiful and it is a lot more than it seems. As Werner Herzog pointed out in his review, it is not a book about a person who is watching a bird. It
音乐 大家好，我是乔尔·布莱克斯托克（Joel Blackstock），欢迎收听Taproot Therapy Collective播客。今天我们要阅读一篇文章，题目是《联觉：融合感官以提炼灵魂》。在开始讨论联觉，或者在定义它（如果你还不知道它是什么的话）之前，我们先来看看《游隼》（The Peregrine）这本书中的一段话，这是我最喜欢的书之一。这是一位博物学家的观鸟日记，听起来枯燥透顶，但它非常优美，而且远不止表面看起来那么简单。正如沃纳·赫尔佐格（Werner Herzog）在评论中所指出的，这不是一本关于一个人观察鸟类的书。它
is about a person who is wanting to and maybe becoming a bird. But anyway, this is not a review of the Peregrine. It is an article on synesthesia, so I'm going to begin that reading from this book now. The first bird that I searched for was the nightjar, which used to nest in the valley. Its song is like the sound of a stream of wine spilling out from a height into a deep and booming cask of wood. It is an odorous sound with a bouquet that rises to the quiet sky. In the glare of day, it would seem
是关于一个人想要成为，甚至可能正在变成一只鸟的书。但无论如何，这不是《游隼》的书评，这是一篇关于联觉的文章，所以我现在要开始朗读这本书中的内容。我寻找的第一只鸟是夜鹰，它过去常在山谷里筑巢。它的歌声就像一串葡萄酒从高处倾泻进一个深邃而轰鸣的木桶里的声音。这是一种带有芬芳气味的声音，香气升腾向宁静的天空。在白昼的强光下，它似乎
thinner and drier, but dusk mellow it and give it vintage. If a song could smell, this song would smell of crushed grape and almond and dark wood. The sound spills out and none of it is lost. The whole wood brims with it and then stops. Suddenly, unexpectedly, but the ear hears it. Still, a prolonged and fading echo, draining and winding out among the surrounding trees into the deep stillness between the early stars and the long afterglow. The night jar leaps up joyfully. It glides and flutters, dances, bounces lightly and silently away. Sparrowhawks were always near me in the dusk, like something I meant but could never quite remember. So let's sit for a minute with a couple things going on in that passage,
更稀薄、更干燥，但黄昏使它变得醇厚，赋予它陈年的韵味。如果歌声能有气味，这歌声闻起来会有碎葡萄、杏仁和深色木头的味道。声音倾泻而出，没有一丝流失。整个树林都溢满了这种声音，然后戛然而止。突然，出人意料，但耳朵听到了。依然，那是一阵悠长而渐弱的回声，在周围的树木间流淌、蜿蜒，进入了早期星辰与漫长余晖之间那深沉的寂静中。夜鹰欢快地跃起。它滑翔、扑动、跳舞，轻盈而无声地弹跳着远去。黄昏时分，雀鹰总是在我身边，就像某种我想要表达却永远无法完全记起的东西。所以，让我们花点时间来细细品味这段文字中的几件事，
and you can speculate on why I might include it in an article about synesthesia. Oh, I lost my mic. Okay, there we go. So let's look at the things that is going on in this passage. So in the glare of day, it would seem thinner and drier, but dusk, mellow it and give it vintage. So the sound is being compared to the visual of a wine pouring into a cask. You also have him saying that the air and the quality of light change the way that the ear hears sound. The stream of wine spilling from a height into a deep and booming cask. He describes the sound as having a smell,
你可以推测一下我为什么会把它收录进一篇关于联觉的文章里。哦，我的麦克风掉了。好了，就这样。那么，让我们看看这段文字中发生了什么。文中说“在白昼的强光下，它似乎更稀薄、更干燥，但黄昏使它变得醇厚，赋予它陈年的韵味”。所以，声音被比作葡萄酒倒入木桶的视觉画面。他还提到空气和光线的质量改变了耳朵听到的声音。那股从高处倾泻进深邃而轰鸣的木桶里的葡萄酒流。他描述这种声音带有气味，
and the smell changing based on the color and the texture of light in the air the ear hears it and still a prolonged and fading echo draining and winding out among the surrounding trees or the ear heroes it hears it still sorry i'm not going to read the whole passage again but the perception of sound in the inner world of the mind endures after sensation of sound in the outer world has ended. It's implied because of a visual, because of what he's looking at. So what we're getting here is all of these senses blending together, or not blending together, which is, I think, how we think of synesthesia too often,
而且气味会根据空气中光线的颜色和质地而改变。耳朵听到了它，依然，那是一阵悠长而渐弱的回声，在周围的树木间流淌、蜿蜒。或者说，耳朵听到了，它依然听到了。抱歉，我不会再读一遍全文了，但这种在内心世界对声音的感知，在外部世界的声音感觉结束后依然持续存在。这是因为一种视觉，因为他所看到的东西而暗示出来的。所以我们在这里看到的是所有这些感官融合在一起，或者说没有融合在一起——我认为我们太频繁地这样看待联觉了，
but the senses are influencing each other, and he is perceiving the way that they influence one another, and describing it beautifully. We don't know a whole lot about the author of the Peregrine if you haven't listened to it. It's a short read. It's a short audible. The narration on the audible I actually really like. It does the original justice. We don't know a ton about the author other than he watched birds. A lot of the poison that was in the air at that time, and pesticides were killing the Peregrine, so he thought likely it would not be alive. It is. It hasn't gone extinct. He thought it would not be alive much past his life, and we also know that he was probably suffering from some kind of illness that was probably lethal and probably what killed him. Other than that, we don't really
但感官确实在相互影响，他正在感知它们相互影响的方式，并对其进行了优美的描述。如果你没听过《游隼》的作者，我们对他了解不多。这是一本短篇读物，也是一本短篇有声书。我其实非常喜欢有声书的旁白，它忠实于原著。除了他观察鸟类之外，我们对作者了解不多。当时空气中弥漫的许多毒素和杀虫剂正在杀死游隼，所以他认为它很可能活不长了。它确实还活着，并没有灭绝。他认为它在他有生之年之后可能就活不下去了，我们也知道他当时可能患有某种致命的疾病，这很可能就是导致他死亡的原因。除此之外，我们真的
know a lot other than his house, which is still there. It's an interesting story. If you want to look up the peregrine, we're going to continue on with this article about synesthesia. So we know that we can't see sound and we know that we can't taste it. How does this podcast taste? You also can't smell it. How's my breath? You know, this description of birdsong tickles our other senses, even though we know those things are not a logical one. They're not even an intuitive one, but a metaphor that is kind of, you know, deep in the mind. It's not that it felt like this. It's just that these things are each other. You know, you might hear style writers describe colors or patterns as loud, or food writers describe taste as shining or dull.
了解不多，只知道他的房子还在那里。这是一个有趣的故事。如果你想查阅《游隼》，我们将继续阅读这篇关于联觉的文章。我们知道我们看不见声音，也尝不出它的味道。这个播客尝起来是什么味道？你也闻不到它。我的口气怎么样？你知道，这种对鸟鸣的描述触动了我们的其他感官，尽管我们知道这些东西在逻辑上是不成立的。它们甚至不是直觉上的，而是一种深藏于心智中的隐喻。并不是说它感觉像这样，而是这些事物本身就是彼此。你知道，你可能会听到文体作家用“响亮”来形容颜色或图案，或者美食作家用“闪耀”或“沉闷”来形容味道。
And this is obviously, this is a synesthetic association, and since the writers are not talking about the food's ability to reflect light or make noise, synesthesia is when the senses blend. It's a condition that is a medical term, and it's a fascinating phenomenon where the stimulation of one sensory or cognitive pathway triggers involuntarily another experience. So, you know, a lot of times people will describe synesthesia as that they ate mushrooms and then that mushroom made them eat the color yellow or smell what their friend was saying or, you know, speak a vision or something. And it isn't always just one sense is being used the wrong way. It is a deep commingling of the senses, um, that is kind of profound. And what I'm arguing in this article is not just, you know, a symptom,
这显然是一种联觉联想，既然作家们谈论的不是食物反射光线或发出噪音的能力，那么联觉就是感官融合的时候。这是一种医学术语，是一种迷人的现象，即一种感官或认知途径的刺激会不由自主地触发另一种体验。所以，你知道，很多时候人们会描述联觉，说他们吃了蘑菇，然后那个蘑菇让他们吃到了黄色，或者闻到了他们朋友说的话，或者，你知道，说出了一种幻象之类的。这并不总是仅仅一种感官被错误地使用。这是一种深刻的感官交融，嗯，这相当深奥。我在本文中要论证的不仅仅是，你知道，一种症状，
but it's actually experiencing of the way that the deep brain works before our brain filters and puts all this stuff back together. So synesthesia is, you know, when it's, it can be a bad symptom and some people that want to get rid of it. But it also is not just a bad thing that is happening wrong. It is kind of us getting a little peek into the perception of the deep brain. And so, you know, there's a cousin of Charles Darwin and he coins the term synesthesia and he begins documenting various cases. But it is a very old phenomenon in our psyche. You know, synesthetic experiences, they've left traces throughout human history, so we know that this is something that goes back a long time. It's definitely not invented in Darwin's time. And manifesting, you know, they show up in ancient mythology, art, and religious practices. So the concept of rasa,
而是它实际上是在体验大脑深层的工作方式，在我们的大脑过滤并把所有这些东西重新组合在一起之前。所以联觉是，你知道，当它，它可能是一种糟糕的症状，有些人想要摆脱它。但它也不仅仅是一件出了问题的坏事。它有点像是让我们窥探到了大脑深层的感知。所以，你知道，查尔斯·达尔文的一位表亲创造了“联觉”这个词，并开始记录各种案例。但这在我们的人类心理中是一个非常古老的现象。你知道，联觉体验在人类历史上留下了痕迹，所以我们知道这是一种由来已久的东西。它绝对不是在达尔文时代才发明的。而且它表现出来，你知道，它们出现在古代神话、艺术和宗教实践中。所以“味”（Rasa）的概念，
for example, in Indian aesthetic philosophy associates emotion with specific colors, taste, and musical tones. For example, the emotion of love is often associated with the color red, or the taste of sweet with certain kinds of round musical tone. And in the Greek world, the poet Sappho, there's a lot of references to synesthetic experience in her work and a lot of other Greek work in Latin. For one, you know, Sappho writes, as I listen, the faint scent of lemon trees rises in the sound of your voice. The poems of the Persian poet Rumi, who is a mystic that I like a lot, they often employ a synesthetic language that describes a spiritual experience. For example, Rumi writes,
例如，在印度美学哲学中，将情感与特定的颜色、味道和音乐音调联系起来。例如，爱的感觉通常与红色联系在一起，或者甜味与某种圆润的音乐音调联系在一起。在希腊世界，诗人萨福（Sappho）的作品中有很多关于联觉体验的引用，在其他许多希腊和拉丁作品中也是如此。例如，你知道，萨福写道：“当我倾听时，柠檬树淡淡的香气在你的声音中升起。”波斯诗人鲁米（Rumi）的诗歌，他是我非常喜欢的一位神秘主义者，他们经常使用一种描述精神体验的联觉语言。例如，鲁米写道：
The flute of the infinite is played without ceasing, and its sound is love. Whoever hears this sound merges into it. In the Bible, you also have a synesthetic description, taste and see that the Lord is good. This is probably not telling you to eat God. Here, the act of tasting is metaphorically linked with this experience of the goodness of God or the flavor of God.
“无限的长笛不停地吹奏，它的声音就是爱。任何听到这声音的人都会融入其中。”在《圣经》中，你也有联觉的描述：“你们要尝尝主恩的滋味，便知道他是美善。”这可能不是让你去吃上帝。在这里，品尝的行为在隐喻上与这种上帝的良善或上帝的味道的体验联系在一起。
And these ancient poets use these synesthetic-like associations to enhance this transcendental effect of their writing, as ancient poets use these synesthetic-like associations to enhance this transcendental effect of their writing, as we still use it today. You feel something a little bit different than if I was like, I saw a bird, the bird went in the sky, the bird had wings, the bird ate a worm. That is, you know, not what the peregrine is. The Hindu philosophy of chakras points, you know, it posits that there's this association and cross-activation between somatic experiences in different parts of the body. So chakras have a physical location in the body, like a somatic association, an emotional association, and then also a color. And then in other kinds of practice, there's also a link between different kinds of energy or sound frequency.
这些古代诗人使用这些类似联觉的联想来增强他们作品的超验效果，正如我们今天仍然在使用它一样。你感觉到的东西和你如果说“我看到了一只鸟，鸟飞上了天，鸟有翅膀，鸟吃了一条虫子”是不一样的。那，你知道，不是《游隼》的内容。印度教的脉轮（Chakras）哲学指出，你知道，它假设身体不同部位的躯体体验之间存在这种联想和交叉激活。所以脉轮在身体中有物理位置，就像一种躯体联想、情感联想，然后还有一种颜色。在其他类型的实践中，不同类型的能量或声音频率之间也存在联系。
So they're kind of saying that like this sort of sound evokes this kind of emotion. That emotion is stored in this place in the body physically, and the body is also responding to this kind of color. So it's, you know, it is this kind of deep synesthetic, you know, fusion of senses that was used in ancient medicine and still today by some people. Chakras, you know, could have provided our ancestors with this framework to understand and regulate their physical and emotional well-being you know when they felt bad they knew that if they went and
所以他们有点像是说，这种声音唤起了这种情感。那种情感在身体上储存在身体的这个位置，身体也对这种颜色做出反应。所以，你知道，这是一种深刻的联觉，你知道，感官的融合，这在古代医学中被使用，今天仍被一些人使用。脉轮，你知道，可能为我们的祖先提供了一个理解和调节他们身心健康的框架，你知道，当他们感觉不好时，他们知道如果他们去
they recognized the emotion of what what is it it's anger i'm going to look at red i'm going to feel this here i'm going to have this sound you know there was this way of kind of recognizing and regulating and rebalancing um so you know by linking specific emotions and bodily sensations to different energy centers represented by chakras, the individuals in the past might have been able to identify and address imbalances in their physical and emotional states. So the color association with chakras may also have served as this visual aid to enhance the focus and awareness of these energy centers during meditation and spiritual practice. You know, colors have a very strong psychological and physiological effect on
他们识别出了那种情感，是什么？是愤怒，我要看红色，我要在这里感觉到这个，我要有这个声音，你知道，有一种识别、调节和重新平衡的方法，嗯，所以，你知道，通过将特定的情感和身体感觉与脉轮所代表的不同能量中心联系起来，过去的人们可能已经能够识别并解决他们身心状态中的失衡。因此，与脉轮相关的颜色也可能作为一种视觉辅助工具，在冥想和精神实践中增强对这些能量中心的关注和觉知。你知道，颜色对
individuals, and using specific colors in association with chakras might have facilitated a deeper connection with activation of these energy centers. Synesthesia may have helped shaman and philosophers perceive these sensory associations. They were intuitive people. They could kind of get underneath cognition and experience it in a way that was a little bit more close to the bottom of the brain or, you know, more pure or more dissociated, whatever you want to call it. And then when they took these realizations out of that transcendental state, they were able to use them to help other people who did not have that heightened perception heal. You know, in the same way that, you know, most counselors are going to be intuitive feeler types that have a different, you know, background than somebody who goes into a different field. So, you know, in the same way that, you know, most counselors are going to be intuitive feeler types, uh, that have a different background than somebody who goes into a different
个人有非常强烈的心理和生理影响，使用与脉轮相关的特定颜色可能促进了与这些能量中心激活的更深层联系。联觉可能帮助萨满和哲学家感知这些感官联想。他们是直觉敏锐的人。他们可以深入到认知之下，以一种更接近大脑底层的方式去体验它，或者，你知道，更纯粹或更解离，随你怎么称呼它。然后，当他们把这些领悟从那种超验状态中带出来时，他们能够利用它们来帮助那些没有那种高度感知能力的人进行疗愈。你知道，就像，你知道，大多数咨询师都是直觉感受型的人，他们有着与进入不同领域的人不同的背景。所以，你知道，就像，你知道，大多数咨询师都是直觉感受型的人，嗯，他们有着与进入不同
field. So, you know, synesthesia also has found a lot of expression in the works of, um, I like a ton of transcendentalist painters. Um, no one really knows about Emil Biestrom, um, which made his work really cheap until I found out about him about, you know, five years ago and really wanted to buy the stuff. Now it's tens of thousands of dollars. So I guess people are finding out about it. I have reproductions of some of that in my office. Um, that's, it looks a lot like Helma off Clint. Um, Wassily Kandinsky also is like a really interesting artist that does a lot of things trying to replicate cross sensory experiences. And I think he actually says synesthesia in one of them. So, you know, synesthesia has always been linked to this increase in neural plasticity, which is the
领域的人不同的背景。所以，你知道，联觉也在许多作品中找到了表达，嗯，我非常喜欢很多超验主义画家。嗯，没人真正了解埃米尔·比斯特罗姆（Emil Bistrom），这使得他的作品非常便宜，直到我大约五年前发现他，并真的很想买他的东西。现在它价值数万美元。所以我猜人们正在发现它。我的办公室里有他的一些复制品。嗯，那，它看起来很像希尔玛·阿夫·克林特（Hilma af Klint）。瓦西里·康定斯基（Wassily Kandinsky）也是一位非常有趣的艺术家，他做了很多事情试图复制跨感官体验。而且我认为他在其中一个作品中实际上提到了联觉。所以，你知道，联觉一直与这种神经可塑性的增加联系在一起，这是
brain's ability to reorganize and establish new connections, which is a useful thing. But sometimes the experience of a very heightened plasticity is distressing. So, you know, it is a thought that it's thought that in individuals with synesthesia, there might be this heightened neural plasticity and certain brain regions and circuits can you know grow so fast that they grow over each other or knit together in a way that a more segmented uh brain as neural network would not you know highly intuitive people like poets or artists they might naturally be more able to form these synesthetic connections because you know the biggest neurological theory about why synesthesia happens that we have is that different uh percepture excuse me like sensory and perceptual networks in the brain are growing over each other or there's crosstalk between them so if you're
大脑重组和建立新连接的能力，这是一件有用的事情。但有时这种高度可塑性的体验是令人痛苦的。所以，你知道，人们认为在联觉患者中，可能存在这种高度的神经可塑性，某些大脑区域和回路可以，你知道，生长得太快，以至于它们长在一起，或者以一种更分段的、嗯，大脑作为神经网络不会有的方式编织在一起。你知道，高度直觉的人，比如诗人或艺术家，他们可能天生就更能形成这些联觉连接，因为，你知道，关于联觉为什么会发生的最大的神经学理论是，大脑中不同的，嗯，感知，抱歉，比如感官和感知网络正在相互生长，或者它们之间存在串扰。所以如果你
growing a whole lot of neural connections very quickly it would be more likely that that would happen um you know genetic factors and please don't send me an email and say that's not provable i know it's not provable. I'm speculating about things after reading a whole lot about what is neuroscientifically plausible, but has not yet been researched and maybe never will because there are so many variables and this stuff is something that we really can only speculate about. So genetic factors, you know, there are some genetic factors that show that synesthesia shows up in certain populations that also have these traits. So I think it's safe to make an assumption that maybe there is a relationship. You know, there's a recent advance in neuroscience that has shed a lot of light on these mechanisms.
正在非常迅速地生长大量的神经连接，那么这种情况发生的可能性就会更大，嗯，你知道，遗传因素，请不要给我发电子邮件说那无法证明，我知道它无法证明。我是在阅读了大量关于神经科学上合理但尚未被研究，也许永远不会被研究的东西之后，对这些事情进行推测，因为变量太多了，这些东西是我们真正只能推测的东西。所以遗传因素，你知道，有一些遗传因素表明联觉出现在某些也具有这些特征的人群中。所以我认为做一个假设，也许存在某种关系是安全的。你知道，神经科学最近的进展已经对这些机制有了很多了解。
And so a lot of fMRI studies have been able to see that there's this certain pattern of brain activity in people with synesthesia. And they indicate that synesthesia does involve like a hyperconnected and increased communication between different brain regions, which generally shows up in people who tend to be very intuitive and people who tend to have a very high neuroplasticity. And a lot of times those people also have other symptoms like dissociation and things that you would expect to go along with a lot of theta wave in the brain. So allowing for this crosstalk between sensory pathways is maybe one reason that that's happening, but there's a lot of different ways that we can, well, for lack of a better word,
所以很多功能性磁共振成像（fMRI）研究已经能够看到，联觉患者的大脑活动存在这种特定的模式。它们表明联觉确实涉及大脑不同区域之间的高度连接和增加的交流，这通常出现在那些往往非常直觉、且往往具有非常高神经可塑性的人身上。很多时候，这些人还有其他症状，比如解离，以及你期望伴随大脑中大量θ波而出现的其他事情。所以允许这种感官途径之间的串扰可能是这种情况发生的一个原因，但有很多不同的方式我们可以，嗯，用一个更好的词来说，
have synesthesia without being diagnosed with synesthesia. You're not going to meet criteria for the diagnosis if you display some of these things, but I'm still going to say that they are related phenomenon that I'm going to still call synesthesia for the purpose of this article. So if you're on the podcast only, you're not on the blog having me read this to you, then you can't see these shapes. But there are two shapes. One is rounded.
在没有被诊断为联觉的情况下拥有联觉。如果你表现出其中一些东西，你不会符合诊断标准，但我仍然会说它们是相关的现象，为了本文的目的，我仍然称之为联觉。所以如果你只听播客，没有在博客上让我读给你听，那么你就看不到这些形状。但有两个形状。一个是圆形的。
It looks kind of like an amoeba, like a splatter. And another one of them has pointy points like a star you know and so there's a famous experiment that's replicated tons of times um where they ask people hey one of these shapes is named boo-boo and the other one is named kiki so which one is which most people um especially in the western world vast majority will say that the shape with pointy points is called kiki and the shape with rounded edges is called boo-boo because we have this uh that the shape with pointy points is called kiki and the shape with rounded edges is called boo boo because we have this uh that the the word that they call it they don't call it synesthesia but i think it's a related phenomenon um they call it sound symbolism is the
它看起来有点像变形虫，像一滩溅出的东西。另一个有尖角，像星星，你知道，所以有一个著名的实验被重复了无数次，嗯，他们问人们：“嘿，这些形状中有一个叫‘布布’（bouba），另一个叫‘奇奇’（kiki），那么哪个是哪个？”大多数人，嗯，特别是在西方世界，绝大多数人会说有尖角的形状叫“奇奇”，有圆边的形状叫“布布”，因为我们有这个，嗯，那个他们称之为的词，他们不叫它联觉，但我认为这是一个相关的现象，嗯，他们称之为声音象征主义（sound symbolism），是
the phenomenon in the brain where different sounds are related to other senses like shape because we feel like there's a relationship but you know i can't tell you why that is. Like I can't get an Excel spreadsheet or something and show you that, but it just makes sense to my brain to say kiki is sharp because there's a, there's a consonant that is, uh, falls off faster when you have like a very sharp vowel and you also have a higher pitch. And those just things seem pointy to me. Where if I say boo, boo, boo, boo, that seems like a very round shape because the consonant, the vowel falls off the consonant at a much longer arc, which to me feels round. And there's also a deep, deeperness to it. There's a depth to the sound, not just that the pitch is lower, but that there's kind of a more of a roll. Your vocal cords are kind of almost harmonizing
大脑中的一种现象，即不同的声音与形状等其他感官相关联，因为我们觉得它们之间存在某种关系，但你知道，我无法告诉你为什么会这样。就像我无法拿出一个Excel电子表格之类的东西向你展示，但我的大脑觉得说“奇奇”是尖锐的很有道理，因为有一个，有一个辅音，当你有一个非常尖锐的元音时，它会消失得更快，而且你还有一个更高的音调。而那些东西对我来说就是尖尖的。如果我说“布布，布布”，那看起来像一个非常圆的形状，因为辅音，元音从辅音上消失的弧度要长得多，这对我来说感觉是圆的。而且它还有一种深沉感。声音有一种深度，不仅仅是音调更低，而是有一种更多的滚动感。你的声带几乎是在
on lower notes. And so there's something about that that feels bigger and rounder, but I can't tell you why. And most people, especially in the Western world, agree with me. So this is another phenomenon that I think is interesting. And so there's no logical basis. There's nothing that makes sense. We just know that brains sort of associate these. And when you think about it, I don't know, it makes sense to my brain but I don't know why. So you know in sound symbolism there's this tendency for people to perceive a correspondence between the sounds of words and the meanings or qualities of associated words. And so like for kiki and boo-boo that's names, but the sound properties of
较低的音符上进行某种和声。所以关于这一点，有些东西感觉更大、更圆，但我无法告诉你为什么。而且大多数人，特别是在西方世界，都同意我的观点。所以这是另一个我认为很有趣的现象。所以这没有逻辑基础。没有什么是有意义的。我们只是知道大脑会以这种方式进行联想。当你想到它时，我不知道，我的大脑觉得很有道理，但我不知道为什么。所以，你知道，在声音象征主义中，人们倾向于感知词语的声音与相关词语的含义或品质之间的对应关系。所以就像“奇奇”和“布布”那样，那是名字，但声音属性
a word can imitate kind of any object or action or concept. And so without going way into the woods, because a lot of these studies are done in different languages or across different languages, I don't speak a ton of languages. And so I can't sit and parse like all of this linguistics in these research articles, you know, super accurately. So you just have to believe me on all that or not. I won't say can't, I'm not going to do that. But the phenomenon has been observed across different languages and cultures. And so one thing that's kind of interesting is, for example, like many languages show this tendency to associate certain speech sounds with a size or shape. So words that
一个词可以模仿任何物体、动作或概念。所以，不用深入丛林，因为很多这些研究是在不同的语言中或跨越不同的语言进行的，我不会说很多语言。所以我不能坐下来，非常准确地解析这些研究文章中的所有语言学内容。所以你只能相信我所说的一切，或者不信。我不会说不能，我不会那样做。但这种现象已经在不同的语言和文化中被观察到了。所以有一件事很有趣，例如，许多语言都表现出将某些语音与大小或形状联系起来的倾向。所以那些
convey smallness or lightness often contain these high-pitched vowels. So it's not just the shape of the sound, it's actually the size. So it's not just a sharp angle for kiki, but people would think that boo-boo, like I was saying, there's more depth to that. There's more resonance. It's bigger. And that maybe is affected by the way that if I yell into a tiny box, it's going to have a higher pitch. If I yell into a big room, it's going to echo. And then maybe the feeling of depth, I don't know. But this pattern can be observed when you look at the way language is structured, because you have things like tiny or big versus light versus heavy. And you can feel the way that those words are structured with certain vowels based on the way that we perceive those vowels to appear, you know, to be seen in a visual way that, you know, sound doesn't do.
传达微小或轻盈的词语通常包含这些高音调的元音。所以这不仅仅是声音的形状，实际上是大小。所以这不仅仅是“奇奇”的尖角，人们会认为“布布”，就像我刚才说的，它有更多的深度。它有更多的共鸣。它更大。这也许受到这种方式的影响：如果我对着一个小盒子大喊，它会有更高的音调。如果我对着一个大房间大喊，它会有回声。然后也许那种深度的感觉，我不知道。但当你观察语言的结构方式时，这种模式是可以观察到的，因为你有像“微小”或“巨大”与“轻”与“重”这样的词。你可以感觉到这些词是如何用特定的元音构建的，基于我们感知这些元音的方式，你知道，以一种视觉方式被看到，你知道，声音做不到这一点。
It's not usually a visual concept, but you know, sound doesn't do. It's not usually a visual concept, but you can see that assumption in language. So sound symbolism is this synesthetic phenomenon behind the association between the names Kiki and Boo Boo. But also there's like a lot of other examples where things have come like to represent smoothness, roughness, brightness, darkness, hardness. And then those same sounds show up in all these different languages. We have these sonic associations that can influence people's perception. And so when you're talking about that kind of crosstalk where this just makes sense, you know, to most people, and most people don't have synesthesia, like just because
它通常不是一个视觉概念，但你知道，声音做不到这一点。它通常不是一个视觉概念，但你可以在语言中看到那种假设。所以声音象征主义是“奇奇”和“布布”这两个名字之间联想背后的联觉现象。但还有很多其他的例子，事物已经变得像是在代表光滑、粗糙、明亮、黑暗、坚硬。然后同样的声音出现在所有这些不同的语言中。我们有这些声音联想，可以影响人们的感知。所以当你谈论那种串扰时，这只是对大多数人来说很有道理，而且大多数人没有联觉，就像仅仅因为
you do sound symbolism, which is almost everybody or most people, that doesn't mean you have synesthesia. But I'm saying that it's normal for everyone to be a little bit synesthetic. And a bigger thesis of this is that the deep brain, all of these senses are mixed together. That's like how new neuroscience is saying that. And then it's taken apart and filtered before we can perceive it into this sensory data. But in that sensory data, the senses already kind of influenced each other on this unconscious level. You know, how exactly that happens or the implications of that, we're not going to get into all of it, nor could we probably. But my thesis here is that synesthesia is maybe representing the way that we think in the unconscious dimension in the subcortical brain,
你进行声音象征主义，也就是几乎每个人或大多数人，那并不意味着你有联觉。但我是在说，每个人都有点联觉是很正常的。而这更大的论点是，大脑深层，所有这些感官都是混合在一起的。这就是新的神经科学所说的。然后它在我们可以将其感知为这种感官数据之前被拆解和过滤。但在那些感官数据中，感官已经在这种潜意识层面上相互影响了。你知道，这究竟是如何发生的，或者其含义是什么，我们不会深入探讨所有这些，我们可能也做不到。但我的论点是，联觉也许代表了我们在潜意识维度、在皮层下大脑中的思考方式，
and then later on the brain is refiltering that, and then there's some artifacts of that process filtering being left over. So these things do influence us. Color influences mood in a way that people talk about. But I still think we talk about it in a very abstract way. So, you know, in my article about architecture, several of them, I argue that there's this evolutionary basis for different forms of art and design, that we don't just design buildings randomly, that there's
然后后来大脑在重新过滤它，然后那个过滤过程留下了一些残留物。所以这些东西确实影响了我们。颜色以人们谈论的方式影响情绪。但我仍然认为我们以一种非常抽象的方式谈论它。所以，你知道，在我关于建筑的文章中，其中几篇，我论证了艺术和设计的不同形式存在这种进化基础，我们不仅仅是随机设计建筑，而是
something in it that makes a building timeless, and that that remains cross-culturally relevant. Additionally, recent studies have indicated that associations between taste and shape are different among cultural groups, which is interesting because it means that whatever that association between taste and shape is, it doesn't run as deep into the brain as the one with sound. So it's probably a newer neural network, and it's going to be different among cultural groups. Some of the other ones may have been there since the Stone Age, and other ones may have developed relatively recently. So they did a study in Africa, and they went and they had these different shape associations with taste, and they asked the people to basically draw the tastes in Westerners
其中有一些东西使建筑永恒，并且在跨文化中保持相关性。此外，最近的研究表明，味道和形状之间的联想在不同文化群体中是不同的，这很有趣，因为这意味着无论味道和形状之间的那种联想是什么，它在大脑中并不像声音那样深入。所以它可能是一个较新的神经网络，并且在不同文化群体中会有所不同。其他一些可能自石器时代以来就存在了，而另一些可能是在相对较近的时间里发展起来的。所以他们在非洲做了一项研究，他们去做了这些不同的形状与味道的联想，并要求人们基本上把味道画出来，在西方人
and in these rural African tribes that hadn't been exposed to, you know, culture advertising or things where they would maybe have some sort of advertising association. They drew it totally differently. Mainly like sweetness and bitterness. They would draw to have different visual properties. So that's what's kind of interesting is like you could call these archetypes, I guess, maybe like the archetypes around taste need to be reprogrammed more readily because climate changes and environment changes or people migrate, whereas something other things change and it would make sense that taste is a more kind of culturally associated, uh, less universal, um, and less deep in the brain neural network.
和这些农村非洲部落中，他们没有接触过，你知道，文化广告或可能让他们有某种广告联想的东西。他们画得完全不同。主要是像甜味和苦味。他们会画出具有不同的视觉属性。所以这就是有趣的地方，你可以称这些为原型，我想，也许像味道周围的原型需要更容易地被重新编程，因为气候变化和环境变化，或者人们迁移，而其他一些东西发生了变化，味道是一种更具文化联想的、嗯，不那么普遍的、嗯，在大脑神经网络中不那么深的东西，这很有道理。
So, you know, a research study that they conducted across a whole bunch of different, um, languages, English, French, German, um, shows that color metaphors to convey emotions like anger, sadness, envy, they had small variations, but usually not very big. So color is a lot more of a universal association than taste. And the networks in the brain that are needed to, you know, rewire and form these new associations between our senses and emotions, you know, this probably is pretty closely tied to instinct,
所以，你知道，他们在一大堆不同的，嗯，语言中进行的一项研究，英语、法语、德语，嗯，显示颜色隐喻来传达愤怒、悲伤、嫉妒等情绪，它们有小的变化，但通常不是很大。所以颜色比味道更是一种普遍的联想。而大脑中需要，你知道，重新连接并形成这些感官和情绪之间的新联想的网络，你知道，这可能与本能紧密相连，
and it was relevant to keeping us alive as we evolved. Now, for example, we might associate colors like red or blue or orange with food if we eat a lot of blueberries and oranges and blackberries and raspberries. And then in an environment without those foods, our associations would need to change. So, you know, other colors or shapes would activate dopamine and taste receptors in a different way. And like I was saying before, some of those probably go a lot deeper into the brain and are harder to get rid of than the other ones that are sort of made to last for 10 years and then maybe be rewired. And so some of these associations between emotion and color and sensation, they run deeper into the brain based on how relevant the need for that association is. So, for example, the shape of a taste might be a relatively recent association due to culture and different genetic groups. It might be more genetic, like that one study would indicate from Africa.
并且在我们进化过程中与保持我们的生存有关。现在，例如，如果我们吃很多蓝莓、橙子、黑莓和覆盆子，我们可能会把红色、蓝色或橙色等颜色与食物联系起来。然后在没有这些食物的环境中，我们的联想就需要改变。所以，你知道，其他颜色或形状会以不同的方式激活多巴胺和味觉受体。就像我之前说的，其中一些可能在大脑中深入得多，比那些旨在持续10年然后可能被重新连接的其他联想更难摆脱。所以这些情绪、颜色和感觉之间的一些联想，根据该联想需求的关联性，在大脑中运行得更深。所以，例如，味道的形状可能是一种相对较新的联想，由于文化和不同的遗传群体。它可能更具遗传性，就像非洲的那项研究可能表明的那样。
And then associations with fire or sharp angles might have a much deeper neural pathway into the brain because they don't change. Poisonous snakes often have a very triangular pointed head. You can tell which snakes are poisonous by the shape of the head. Predators have sharp pointy teeth. As soon as people could make stone tools, they made pointy stuff to throw at each other or animals. And then prehistoric art usually portrays predators. Like if you look at cave art, I'm not going to try and remember or pronounce all those French caves where a lot of that art is. But it portrays like predators like wolves and bears with this triangular shape to the
然后与火或尖角的联想可能在大脑中有一条更深的神经通路，因为它们不会改变。毒蛇通常有一个非常三角形的尖头。你可以通过头的形状分辨出哪些蛇是有毒的。捕食者有锋利的尖牙。一旦人们能够制造石器，他们就制造尖锐的东西来互相投掷或投掷动物。然后史前艺术通常描绘捕食者。就像如果你看洞穴艺术，我不会试图记住或发音所有那些有很多艺术的法国洞穴。但它描绘了像狼和熊这样的捕食者，头部有这种三角形的形状。甚至像一个正在变成水牛人或鹿人的萨满，他们展示那个人是萨满的方式，就像半人半兽，就是头部是三角形的。他们不是人类。他们是一个，他们的一部分是动物。嗯，所以，你知道，这种史前艺术，它，它描绘了很多那种形状。再说一次，这是一个很难证明的理论。这只是一个，嗯，一个想法，但有可能这就是我们认为圆形的形状与人有更多关系的原因。你看看最初的雕刻，或者不是雕刻，因为有骨针和一把小刀之类的东西。但最初的雕刻只是为了艺术，只是为了文化而制作的。
head. And even like a shaman who's becoming like a buffalo person or a deer person, the way that they show that that person is a shaman, like a half animal is that the head is triangular. They're not human. They're an ant that part of them is animal. Um, so, you know, this prehistoric art, it, it portrays that shape a lot. And again, this is a theory that'd be hard to prove. It's just kind of a, uh, an idea, but it's possible that this is the reason that we think rounded shapes have more to do with people. You look at the first carvings, or not carvings, because there's bone picks and little knives and things. But the first carvings that were just made for art, just made for culture.
而且很多人指出这些是旧石器时代宗教的开端。这些是在人类还在进化时制作的。就像我们还不是现代人类。我们基本上还是正在改变的灵长类猴子。大脑中的楔前叶（precuneus）给了你这种自我意识。然后突然之间人们开始试图找出该怎么处理它。我们稍后会做一个关于这个的更长的系列。以及所有来自
And a lot of people point to those as the beginning of religion in the old Stone Age. And these are made when mankind is still evolving. Like we're not modern humans yet. We're basically still primate monkeys that are changing. And the precuneus in the brain gives you this sense of self. And then all of a sudden people start trying to find out what to do with that. And we're going to do a longer series about that later. And all the problems that come from
感知到你与自然分离的问题，这些问题如何需要用某种宗教、艺术或隐喻实践来处理。但当这种情况发生时，人们雕刻的第一件不是为了维持生存的工具的东西就是这些女性形象。它们非常圆。你可能见过维伦多夫的维纳斯（Venus of Willendorf）。如果你见过，它不是最古老的，但它是最著名的之一。如果你看过《年轻的教宗》（The Young Pope），它确实在奥地利博物馆，我在那里见过它，或者我想是维也纳博物馆。我忘了它的名字。我妻子会对我生气。但无论如何，那就是我看到它的地方。那是，你知道，裘德·洛（Jude Law）总是作为宗教领袖与宗教起源进行这种对抗。所以他是这个，你知道，男人显然在看着他办公室角落里的这个女性形象。所有这些维纳斯小雕像都是
perceiving that you are separate from nature, how those need to be handled with something like a religious or artistic or metaphorical practice. But when that happens, the first thing that people carve that is not a tool to keep them alive are these figures of women. And they're very round. You may have seen the Venus of Willendorf. If you've seen, it's not the oldest one, but it's one of the most famous. And if you've seen The Young Pope, it's really in the Austrian Museum where I've seen it, or I think the Viennese Museum. I forget the name of it. My wife would get mad at me. But anyway, that's where I saw it. That's, you know, Jude Law always be having this confrontation as the head of religion with the origin of religion. So he's this, you know, man obviously looking at this female figure that's in the corner of his office. And all of these Venus figurines are
几乎是球形的。它们有一个完全圆形的头。它们看起来几乎像一个圆形的身体。它们有圆形的乳房。它们有一个巨大的肚子。它们在脚和大腿上有巨大的脂肪叶。它们非常多地与这种圆润联系在一起。所以我认为可能存在，你知道，一个相当深刻和古老的联想，即那些混乱的、糟糕的、不是我们的、不是人类的东西，是尖锐的。而那些是我们自己的东西是圆形的、母性的和柔软的。这些维纳斯小雕像，你知道，当然我们永远不知道。这是史前的，你知道，没有文字，但有这样的想法，即他们是在某种程度上崇拜这种生育的想法，以及作为生育者的女性，你能拥有的孩子越多。所以，它们在某种程度上与带来更多的孩子和更多的生育能力有关。所以这些原始人类将自己与此联系起来。
almost spherical. They have a completely rounded head. They almost look like a rounded body. They have round breasts. They have a huge belly. They have like huge lobes of fat on their feet and on their thighs. And they're very much associated with this roundness. And so I think there may be, you know, a pretty deep and ancient association that the stuff that is chaos, that is bad, that is not us, that is not human, is pointy and sharp. And the stuff that is us is round and maternal and soft. And these Venus figurines, you know, of course we never know. It's a prehistoric, you know, there's no writing, but there's the ideas that they were sort of worshiping this idea of childbearing and the more children you could have in the woman as the bearer of children. And so the, they were somehow related to bringing about more children and more fertility. So these primitive humans associated themselves with that.
而且有，他引用了它，它来自20世纪70年代的一项研究，罗达·凯洛格（Rhoda Kellogg）做的。但他引用了它在爱德华·埃丁格（Edward Edinger）的书《自我与原型》（Ego and Archetype）中，这是一本非常好的书。他展示了，比如孩子们从他们很小的时候一直到他们长大，画自我的过程。在那些画中，嗯，你看到起源，比如最初的自我画作只是一个
And there's, he cites it, it's from a 1970s study, Rhoda Kellogg did. But he cites it in Edward Edinger's book, Ego and Archetype, which is a really good book. He shows like children drawing the self from when they're like very little all the way up to when they get bigger. And in those drawings, uh, you see the origin, like the first drawings of self are just a
圆圈，然后圆圈变大，变得更复杂。然后圆圈被一个十字交叉，它变成了四个部分。埃丁格在书中用它来提出这样一个理论，即，你知道，我们可以将自我和早期宗教概念化为一个圆圈，因为我们与太阳和月亮的关系。那是我们最需要的东西。我们认为它们是最，我们通过它们来参照我们自己。你知道，荣格（Jung）非常热衷于这个想法。如果你看《红书》（Red Book），里面有所有这些场景，比如，你知道，一个太阳圆盘在船上被守护，或者像一个人杀死一条龙，它的血里有太阳圆盘出来
circle and then the circle gets bigger and more complicated. And then the circle is bifurcated with a cross and it turns into four parts. And Eddinger's using that in the book to have this theory that, you know, we can conceptualize the self and early religion as a circle because of our relationship to the sun and moon. That was the thing that we needed the most. We thought that they were most, we referenced ourself through them. You know, Jung was really into this idea. If you look in the Red Book, there's all of these scenes of like you know a sun disc being guarded on a boat or like a person killing a dragon and its blood has sun discs coming out
因为它，因为大多数原始宗教都是围绕太阳圆盘建立的，那是，你知道，最古老的部分，第一个神是太阳神，它是一个圆形的太阳圆盘，它只是一个圆圈，通常是金色的，或者有时它被像蛇一样的东西锚定或支撑着。但你看到它仍然是，即使在埃及后来的王国中，但在非常早期的埃及文物中，你看到太阳圆盘是非常主要的。所以无论如何，有这样一种想法，即当宗教开始时，人们将自己和上帝视为仅仅是一个圆圈，然后后来上帝分裂成多个部分，并成为这种多神论的东西，随着我们变得更复杂，我们的文化变得更复杂，它变得更复杂。所以这一切的重点是，可能存在一个相当
of it because most of the primitive religions were built around sun discs that was like the oldest part the first god was the sun god and it was around sun disc it's just a circle that usually is kind of gold or sometimes it's being anchored or held up by something like a snake. But you see that it's still, even in the later kingdoms in Egypt, but in the very early Egyptian artifacts, you see the sun discus being really primary. And so anyway, there's this kind of idea that when religion starts, people view themselves and God as just a circle, and then later God breaks into multiple parts and becomes this polytheistic thing that is more complicated as we become more complicated and our culture becomes more complicated. So the whole point of this is there might be a pretty
因为大多数原始宗教都是围绕太阳圆盘建立的，这是最古老的部分，最初的神就是太阳神，它围绕着太阳圆盘，那只是一个通常呈金色或有时被蛇之类的东西锚定或支撑的圆圈。但你会发现，即使在埃及后期的王国中，在非常早期的埃及文物里，太阳圆盘仍然占据主导地位。总之，有一种观点认为，当宗教开始时，人们将自己和上帝视为一个圆圈，后来上帝分裂成多个部分，变成了多神论，随着我们变得越来越复杂，我们的文化也变得越来越复杂，它也变得更加复杂。所以这一切的重点在于，可能存在一个相当
old association that's still present when children draw themselves at young ages, and you look at that art change, that people are human and round, and that we associate our humanity and our psyche with a circle. And we associate everything else with jagged, painful, predatory teeth and claws and sharp stuff. You know, we are boo-boo and the other thing is geeky. And so the synesthesia, you know, probably helps us listen to the pattern and shape of nature. And it's related to all these kind of evo-psych ideas and Jungian archetypal theory, you know, pointed heads of snakes, and colors, you know, indicated things that we needed to feel. And so, you know, this would
这种古老的联想在孩子们年幼时画自己时依然存在，当你观察这种艺术变化时，会发现人是圆形的，我们将人性与心理与圆形联系在一起。而我们将其他一切事物与锯齿状、痛苦、掠食性的牙齿、爪子和尖锐的东西联系起来。你知道，我们是可爱的，而另一面是怪异的。所以联觉可能有助于我们倾听自然的模式和形状。这与所有这些进化心理学思想和荣格原型理论有关，你知道，蛇的尖头，还有颜色，都暗示了我们需要感受的东西。所以，你知道，这会
need to vary. The plasticity would need to change in different places. And so these studies have shown that there's cultural and genetic groups that have different associations between taste and shape. And then there's also an enormous difference between the information being processed by the brain and the information being perceived by the conscious ego. So especially one of the things that makes us very different than animals is that we're not just processing information.
需要变化。可塑性需要在不同的地方发生改变。因此，这些研究表明，存在着对味觉和形状有不同联想的文化和遗传群体。此外，大脑处理的信息与意识自我感知的信息之间也存在巨大的差异。所以，让我们与动物有很大区别的一点是，我们不仅仅是在处理信息。
We're actually aware of the information that we're processing. You know, perception in everyday life, like our senses constantly receive an enormous amount of information from the environment. And to prevent us from being overwhelmed, our brain filters out certain sensory inputs or the vast majority of sensory input, not certain ones. And that it deems less important or redundant, it puts some of them together, it processes them. You know, it's a pretty advanced algorithm. One example of that is eyes. video footage that your eye is taking at any point and plug it into a computer. Um, you know,
我们实际上意识到我们正在处理的信息。你知道，日常生活中的感知，就像我们的感官不断从环境中接收大量信息。为了防止我们不堪重负，大脑会过滤掉某些感官输入，或者说绝大多数感官输入，而不是特定的某些。它认为不重要或多余的信息，它会将其中一些组合起来，进行处理。你知道，这是一个相当先进的算法。一个例子就是眼睛。你的眼睛在任何时候拍摄的视频片段，并将其插入计算机。嗯，你知道，
just like if you could make it have an HDMI cable or, you know, RCA cable set from the nineties or something, you plug it into the TV and you just look directly at what your brain, your eyes filming. Um, you wouldn't recognize it. I mean, one image is backwards and it flips the image to it's two images that your eye puts together, your brain puts together, both of your eyes, you know, input. And then it uses the binocularity to tell how far apart things are based on where they are, which is pretty complicated. But we could maybe assume that that's happening. But there's even more stuff that's really wild. One of them is that there's blood vessels and sometimes scar tissue or like different things, but definitely blood vessels that run right across the visual plane. So you can't see in certain areas, there's actually blind spots to your
就像如果你能让它有一根HDMI线，或者九十年代的RCA线之类的，你把它插到电视上，直接看你大脑、你的眼睛正在拍摄的东西。嗯，你认不出来。我的意思是，一个图像是反向的，它会翻转图像，这是你的眼睛放在一起的两个图像，你的大脑放在一起，你知道，双眼的输入。然后它利用双眼视觉根据物体的位置来判断距离，这相当复杂。但我们或许可以假设这就是正在发生的事情。但还有更多真正疯狂的东西。其中之一是，有血管，有时还有疤痕组织或类似的东西，但绝对是血管，它们直接穿过视觉平面。所以你在某些区域看不见，实际上你的视觉中有盲点。
vision. And what your brain is doing at all times is it's using the information around that, like a Photoshop dust removal filter to make a guess about that, what that was, and then sort of deinterlace it so you can't see it. So some of the stuff that you see is completely made up by your brain. And, you know, it happens to be right. Because, you know, we rely on it, and we don't perceive that. So you know, that information is being processed, but it's not being perceived. But there's a ton of information that's going on on the space level of the brain that you don't have access to, like, I can't sit here and be like, no, I, my breathing will turn off, you know, like, I will just not notice that I'm breathing if I wait a minute. And then I can't sit here and be like, no, I, my breathing will turn off. You know, like I will just not notice that I'm breathing if I wait a minute and then I can think about it and go, okay, well now I got to remember to breathe until I forget about it again. Then my body takes that over,
而你的大脑一直在做的事情是，它利用周围的信息，就像Photoshop的除尘滤镜一样，对那是什么进行猜测，然后对其进行去隔行处理，这样你就看不见了。所以你看到的一些东西完全是大脑编造的。而且，你知道，它恰好是正确的。因为，你知道，我们依赖它，而我们并没有察觉到这一点。所以你知道，这些信息正在被处理，但并没有被感知。但是大脑的基础层面上有大量的信息是你无法获取的，比如，我不能坐在这里说，不，我的呼吸会停止，你知道，如果我等一分钟，我就不会注意到我在呼吸。然后我不能坐在这里说，不，我的呼吸会停止。你知道，如果我等一分钟，我就不会注意到我在呼吸，然后我可以思考它并说，好吧，现在我得记得呼吸，直到我再次忘记它。然后我的身体接管了它，
but I can't sit here and then say, okay, I'm going to, uh, try and perceive all the blood vessels and blind spots on my eyes and rip that thing apart and perceive the eyes, two different video feeds. And then like, I can't do that. So, you know, the closest thing that you can do is something called prisoner cinema, where if you close your eyes and you look at the blackness behind your eyes, there'll be all these sort of visual tricks that the processing does, and you'll see little blue sparks or whatever. But, you know, I'm going into the woods. But, you know, our brain doesn't show us all of the chaos that it is processing.
但我不能坐在这里然后说，好吧，我要尝试感知我眼睛上的所有血管和盲点，把那个东西拆开，感知眼睛，两个不同的视频源。然后，就像，我做不到。所以，你知道，你能做的最接近的事情就是所谓的囚徒电影，如果你闭上眼睛，看着眼前的黑暗，大脑处理过程中会产生各种视觉技巧，你会看到蓝色的小火花之类的。但是，你知道，我扯远了。但是，你知道，我们的大脑并没有向我们展示它正在处理的所有混乱。
It only shows us what we need to be able to perceive ourself and the world around us. But that doesn't mean that there's not information in that processing where the senses are kind of blending and influencing one another. And things like brain spawning or ETT, color-based therapies, they're sort of hijacking those visual glitches in the brain in order to get trauma out of the body. So, you know, in individuals that have schizophrenia, you know, there's abnormalities in the brain, sensory gating. You know, we used to think that, it doesn't matter, I'm not going to go into the history of that, we used to have different theories about schizophrenia, but the common one now that sort of replaced those is that there's a sensory gating mechanism. It's not that the brain is making something up. It's not that the brain is making something up. It's actually that it isn't filtering something out, that everybody
它只向我们展示了我们需要感知自己和周围世界的东西。但这并不意味着在处理过程中没有感官相互融合和影响的信息。像大脑定位（Brainspotting）或ETT（情绪转化疗法）这样的东西，它们是在劫持大脑中的这些视觉故障，以便将创伤从身体中释放出来。所以，你知道，在患有精神分裂症的个体中，你知道，大脑的感官门控存在异常。你知道，我们过去认为，没关系，我不打算深入探讨那段历史，我们过去对精神分裂症有不同的理论，但现在取代这些理论的普遍观点是存在一种感官门控机制。并不是大脑在编造什么。并不是大脑在编造什么。实际上是它没有过滤掉某些东西，而其他人
else has, you know, this ability to discard all this information. But a person with schizophrenia, they can't tell it apart. And when I used to work with people, I still work with some people that have schizophrenia, but when I used to work only people only that had schizophrenia, you know, that was one of the things they would say is like, everything makes sense to me. And then I say this new thing, and that doesn't make sense to anybody. And they couldn't tell the difference in between what they were, you know, inventing eventually, essentially, and what everyone else assumed, you know, their reality was, you know, 90% the same as everyone else's reality. But then, you know, 10% of it wasn't there. And that's sort of true of everybody. We don't all live in the same perceived world, but we kind of know what things are mine. You
都有，你知道，这种丢弃所有这些信息的能力。但是精神分裂症患者，他们无法区分。当我过去和患有精神分裂症的人一起工作时，我仍然和一些患有精神分裂症的人一起工作，但当我过去只和患有精神分裂症的人一起工作时，你知道，他们会说的一件事就是，一切对我来说都有意义。然后我说这个新东西，这对任何人都没有意义。他们无法区分他们所发明的，本质上，和别人所认为的，你知道，他们的现实，你知道，90%和别人的现实是一样的。但然后，你知道，10%是不存在的。这对于每个人来说都是如此。我们并不是都生活在同一个感知的世界里，但我们多少知道哪些东西是我的。你
know, there's certain hobbies or ideas that I wouldn't just say on the podcast because they, you know, they may not be, I would know that they may be inflammatory or something, whereas somebody else, they don't have that. And it's not that their brain is making up something, it's that it isn't filtering things out. And a lot of delusion is active imagination or wish fulfillment. You know, a lot of psychosis is this unconscious creative process that is making things that are not being labeled as made up or not being discarded. And so the sensory gating theory of schizophrenia, I think, explains a whole lot about the thesis of what I'm trying to say about the way that synesthesia works in the brain. And so, you know, creativity and intuition in humans might be caused by gaps in these sensory gates that allow for unorthodox ways of information
知道，有些爱好或想法我不会在播客上说，因为它们，你知道，它们可能不是，我知道它们可能会引起争议之类的，而其他人，他们没有这种顾虑。这并不是说他们的大脑在编造什么，而是它没有过滤掉东西。很多妄想是主动想象或愿望满足。你知道，很多精神病是这种无意识的创造过程，它制造了一些没有被标记为编造或没有被丢弃的东西。所以精神分裂症的感官门控理论，我认为，解释了关于联觉在大脑中如何运作的论点的很大一部分。所以，你知道，人类的创造力和直觉可能是由这些感官门控中的缝隙引起的，这些缝隙允许非正统的信息处理方式
being processed that end up to be useful. Most evolutionary advantages start off as an accident, and then they're useful, so they stick around. You get too much of it, and that becomes a problem again. For example, sickle cell anemia, the reason that that exists is that people who have the recessive gene for sickle cell anemia, they don't get malaria. The blood cell can't get messed with by this disease, but you have too much of it when you get the dominant one. All of a sudden, this shape of the cell is not different enough to protect you from the virus. It is so different that it can no longer go through your veins, and you're in a ton of pain. And so, you know, these small genetic predispositions to have an imperfect sensory gate,
最终变得有用。大多数进化优势最初都是偶然的，然后它们很有用，所以它们就保留了下来。你得到太多了，那又变成了一个问题。例如，镰状细胞性贫血，它存在的原因是那些拥有镰状细胞性贫血隐性基因的人，他们不会得疟疾。血细胞不会被这种疾病干扰，但当你拥有显性基因时，你就拥有太多了。突然之间，这种细胞的形状不足以保护你免受病毒侵害。它太不同了，以至于它无法再通过你的静脉，你会感到非常痛苦。所以，你知道，这些导致感官门控不完美的微小遗传倾向，
they probably are part of what give us this ability to be creative and intuitive, especially in certain people. And then even in everybody, everybody's brain can be plastic up to a point. So if you start to concentrate on these things and practice creativity and practice intuition and practice mindfulness, then yeah, you start to perceive deeper and deeper layers of the mind. And so it would make sense that people who do those practices have better access to these things that sound a lot like schizophrenia. You know, it's long been speculated that schizophrenia might just be this overabundance or overexpression of the same genes that lead to creativity or new perspectives and new ideas. Creativity and intuition can help us see how to color outside the lines, but when there's too many of those tendencies to break rules, then we can't see the
它们可能就是赋予我们这种创造力和直觉能力的一部分，特别是在某些人身上。而且即使在每个人身上，每个人的大脑在一定程度上都是可塑的。所以如果你开始专注于这些事情，练习创造力，练习直觉，练习正念，那么是的，你开始感知到大脑更深更深的层面。所以，进行这些练习的人能更好地接触到这些听起来很像精神分裂症的东西，这是有道理的。你知道，长期以来人们一直推测，精神分裂症可能只是导致创造力或新视角和新想法的相同基因的过剩或过度表达。创造力和直觉可以帮助我们看到如何跳出框框思考，但当打破规则的倾向太多时，我们就根本看不到
lines at all. We don't even know that we're coloring outside of the lines. Joseph Campbell used to say that the artist swims in the ocean that the person with schizophrenia drowns. I think he actually said schizophrenic, but that's not person, patient-centered language. You can't say that anymore. It's, you know, person with homelessness, not a homeless person. It's person with schizophrenia, which is the right way to say it. But I'm just reading a quote, so if I change it, I want to explain why. So anyway, he, you know, meant there that the deep layers of the unconscious can enrich us, but if we go too deep, then we can lose ourselves.
界限了。我们甚至不知道我们正在跳出框框。约瑟夫·坎贝尔曾经说过，艺术家在精神分裂症患者溺水的海洋中游泳。我想他实际上说的是精神分裂症患者，但那不是以人为本、以患者为中心的语言。你不能再那样说了。它是，你知道，患有无家可归的人，而不是无家可归者。是患有精神分裂症的人，这才是正确的说法。但我只是在读一段引语，所以如果我改了它，我想解释原因。所以无论如何，他，你知道，意思是深层的无意识可以丰富我们，但如果我们走得太深，那么我们可能会迷失自我。
Jung said that the ego has to go down into the unconscious, but if it goes down over and over too deep, then it loses its ability to have any kind of rigidity at all, and no longer is it too rigid. It isn't able to be rigid enough to keep the unconscious out. So our senses are not as distinct as we would like to make them. You know, we think about senses in this ordered way that the ear hears sound and the brain perceives the sound, but that's not really how the brain works. All of our
荣格说自我必须进入无意识，但如果它反复进入太深，那么它就会失去任何僵化的能力，不再过于僵化。它无法足够僵化以将无意识拒之门外。所以我们的感官并不像我们想要的那样独特。你知道，我们以这种有序的方式思考感官，耳朵听到声音，大脑感知声音，但这并不是大脑真正的工作方式。我们所有的
senses are blended together and they send messages to our body and emotional system before the brain stem filters them for us, you know, to be able to feel it. All of our senses are blended together and the brain filters them for us. And the ego consciousness and our self-perception is really one of the smallest parts of who we are. We think it's all we are. The ego wants to be all of who we are. But our brain does an enormous amount of work before the sensations that we perceive are presented to our ego on the silver platter to perceive. And the keys to unlocking our psychology, I think, lie in understanding synesthesia and the spaghettical bowl mess of processing and perception that is taking place in our brain at any moment. Treatments like somatic therapy or emotional transformation therapy, which I got trained in in Texas last weekend, use color and light. It's an eye therapy like brain spotting, but it doesn't use position. It uses color and
感官都是混合在一起的，它们在脑干为我们过滤之前就向我们的身体和情绪系统发送信息，你知道，为了能够感受到它。我们所有的感官都是混合在一起的，大脑为我们过滤它们。而自我意识和我们的自我感知实际上是我们是谁的一小部分。我们认为这就是我们的全部。自我想要成为我们的全部。但在我们感知的感官被呈现在银盘上供我们的自我感知之前，我们的大脑做了大量的工作。我认为解锁我们心理学的关键在于理解联觉以及我们大脑中随时发生的处理和感知的混乱。像躯体疗法或情绪转化疗法（我上周末在德克萨斯州接受了培训）这样的治疗方法，使用颜色和光。这是一种像大脑定位一样的眼部疗法，但它不使用位置。它使用颜色和
light. You can come in and see me and we'll do that. It's pretty wild. Now, you know, what is down there? You know, I watched a piece of paper turn black in front of me that my eyes knew was blue. And it's like, I know this is blue. What is going on? And I watched my eyes turn it black. And that was because I had a traumatic association with one of the emotions that we were working with. And so, you know, older traditions like chakras and transcendental meditation, I mean, they're based on utilizing these same glitches in perception. And while brain spotting uses eye position, EMDR uses eye movement and ETT therapy uses color as a trigger to release trauma from the deep brain. And I'm sure there's other ways in there to use the senses. But, you know, it's long been recognized that there's this powerful stimulus that can elicit emotion and psychological responses in humans within color.
光。你可以来找我，我们会做那个。这很疯狂。现在，你知道，下面有什么？你知道，我看着一张纸在我面前变黑，我的眼睛知道它是蓝色的。就像，我知道这是蓝色的。发生了什么事？我看着我的眼睛把它变黑了。那是因为我对我们正在处理的情绪之一有创伤性的联想。所以，你知道，像脉轮和超觉静坐这样的古老传统，我的意思是，它们是基于利用这些相同的感知故障。虽然大脑定位使用眼睛位置，但EMDR使用眼球运动，而ETT疗法使用颜色作为触发器来释放深层大脑中的创伤。我相信还有其他方法可以使用感官。但是，你知道，长期以来人们已经认识到，颜色中存在这种强大的刺激，可以引发人类的情绪和心理反应。
We disagree on exactly where that comes from or exactly what it is. But we know that color influences us. You know, if it didn't at all, why would we have a preference about color when we bought clothes or painted our house? So there's this potential that color has to do a lot of things in the brain. And much of these happen at this base unconscious level before cognition, before we can even perceive what's happening, which is why we have a hard time understanding what they are or even believing that they're there. So from an evolutionary perspective, this impact of color on trauma and psychology can be explained by this principle of biophilia that we suggest,
我们对它究竟来自哪里或它究竟是什么意见不一。但我们知道颜色会影响我们。你知道，如果它完全没有影响，为什么我们在买衣服或粉刷房子时会对颜色有偏好呢？所以颜色在大脑中做很多事情是有潜力的。其中大部分发生在认知之前的这种基础无意识层面，在我们甚至能感知到发生了什么之前，这就是为什么我们很难理解它们是什么，甚至很难相信它们存在。因此，从进化的角度来看，颜色对创伤和心理的这种影响可以用我们建议的这种亲生命性原则来解释，
you know, or biophilia says that humans have this natural tendency to try and connect with nature or compare themselves to nature. And then as we move further away from nature or natural principles, we become more healthy. And that doesn't mean that away from nature or natural principles, we become more healthy. And that doesn't mean that you shouldn't cook your food and you should go on a paleo diet and only eat nuts. It means that we've kind of evolved to do certain specific things for a reason. They kept us alive. And the more you try and bend human nature away from those things, the more problems happen. Now, you know, politically or philosophically or culturally, you have fights about what's natural and what's not.
你知道，或者亲生命性说人类有一种试图与自然联系或将自己与自然进行比较的自然倾向。然后，当我们离自然或自然原则越来越远时，我们变得更健康。这并不意味着离自然或自然原则越来越远，我们变得更健康。这并不意味着你不应该烹饪食物，你应该进行旧石器饮食，只吃坚果。这意味着我们进化出某些特定的事情是有原因的。它们让我们活了下来。你越是试图让人的本性偏离这些事情，发生的问题就越多。现在，你知道，在政治上、哲学上或文化上，你会对什么是自然的，什么不是自然的进行争论。
So that's not what I'm trying to say. I'm not trying to argue for any sort of political position. What I'm saying is just that the more that you make people do things that they were not designed to do, the harder it is for them to do those things. Some maybe are good things that we should do, and then some maybe are bad things that we should not. I mean, one example, I think when you get into huge scale systems, like something like climate change, you are looking at something that is so big and so complicated and so many balls have to hit the next thing that we just, we understand systems on a one, two, and then very intelligent individuals can see things at a three and four step process. And then beyond that, we have to rely on something like equations or, you know, spreadsheets or, you know, these things that keep
所以这不是我想说的。我不是在为任何政治立场辩护。我想说的是，你越是让人做他们本不被设计去做的事情，他们做这些事情就越困难。有些可能是我们应该做的好事，有些可能是我们不应该做的坏事。我的意思是，一个例子，我认为当你进入大规模系统时，比如气候变化之类的东西，你看到的是一个如此巨大、如此复杂的东西，有太多的球必须击中下一个东西，以至于我们只是，我们在一步、两步的层面上理解系统，然后非常聪明的人可以在三步和四步的过程中看到事物。除此之外，我们必须依赖像方程，或者，你知道，电子表格，或者，你知道，这些保持
track of complex logic for us. You know, AI is a pretty good example because what AI is doing is it's using the statistical engine to grab all these things on the internet. A ton of times, there's so many things that it grabs, it doesn't even know why it thinks that. You know, there's a court case that was brought against a county where they were using basically an AI that was a black box algorithm to try and predict if somebody was going to be a recidivist, if they were going to offend after they were let out of prison again. And so they were using it for parole and people brought a court case against it. And they said, you know, you can't do that because you're not able to tell me why you think that my client is a threat. And it, you know, it was upheld. They said, yeah,
复杂逻辑跟踪的东西。你知道，人工智能是一个很好的例子，因为人工智能正在做的是它使用统计引擎来抓取互联网上的所有这些东西。很多时候，它抓取的东西太多了，它甚至不知道为什么它会那样想。你知道，有一个针对一个县的法庭案件，他们基本上在使用一种人工智能，那是一个黑盒算法，试图预测某人是否会成为累犯，如果他们在被释放出狱后是否会再次犯罪。所以他们把它用于假释，人们对此提起了诉讼。他们说，你知道，你不能那样做，因为你无法告诉我为什么你认为我的客户是一个威胁。而且，你知道，它被维持原判了。他们说，是的，
we don't know. And neither does the AI. There's just too much information going through there, but it is right. You know, we've looked at it and the things that it's doing are correct. So we're going to go with what it says. You know, so climate change, I think is an example of what I'm saying here. Like that's maybe something where we should learn to do something that's not terribly natural, um, because we can't even understand the complexity of that issue and what it means enough to act on it because we're not designed to do that, do that. Um, and it means that there could be pretty big catastrophic consequences if we don't. Um, but you know, evolutionary psychology and archetypal theory, they propose
我们不知道。人工智能也不知道。那里流经的信息太多了，但它是正确的。你知道，我们已经看过了，它正在做的事情是正确的。所以我们将按照它说的去做。你知道，所以气候变化，我认为是我在这里所说的一个例子。那可能是一个我们应该学习做一些不太自然的事情的地方，嗯，因为我们甚至无法理解那个问题的复杂性以及它意味着什么，以至于无法采取行动，因为我们不是被设计来做那个的。嗯，这意味着如果我们不这样做，可能会有相当大的灾难性后果。嗯，但是，你知道，进化心理学和原型理论，它们提出
that certain colors have this deep-rooted symbolic meaning and they can evoke this archetypal response within you. And these archetypes are thought to be universal and inherited and represent fundamental human experiences and emotions. But for example, red can evoke passion or danger or energy, and blue may elicit calmness and tranquility and even sadness. And these archetypal associations with colors have developed over time as adaptive responses to the environment. So to talk about that ETT therapy, just real fast, you know, its use of specific colors and hypothetical mechanisms can be derived, you know, both, you can look at them, you
某些颜色具有这种根深蒂固的象征意义，它们可以在你内心唤起这种原型反应。这些原型被认为是普遍的和遗传的，代表了基本的人类经验和情绪。但例如，红色可以唤起激情或危险或能量，蓝色可能会引起平静和安宁，甚至悲伤。这些与颜色的原型联想是随着时间的推移作为对环境的适应性反应而发展的。所以谈谈那个ETT疗法，很快地，你知道，它对特定颜色和假设机制的使用可以推导出来，你知道，两者，你可以从荣格或进化的角度来看待它们，你
know, from a Jungian or evolutionary standpoint, but ETT uses this set of color filters that influence emotional states and facilitate therapeutic transformation. And from an evolutionary perspective, those colors and light directions that ETT is using, they may tap into these primal associations with where the sun is and what angle it's coming from and what color things are. That's probably where they come from. I don't think that our brain decided to do something that complicated at random, and I've seen it have some pretty profound effects. So, for instance, using calming shades of green or blue might activate this connection with natural landscapes and trigger relaxation responses and potentially reduce stress or trauma related symptoms. And then from a Jungian standpoint, the colors employed in ETT,
知道，但ETT使用这套颜色滤镜，它们影响情绪状态并促进治疗性转变。从进化的角度来看，ETT正在使用的那些颜色和光线方向，它们可能利用了这些原始的联想，关于太阳在哪里，它从什么角度射入，以及事物是什么颜色。这可能就是它们的来源。我不认为我们的大脑随机决定做那么复杂的事情，而且我已经看到它产生了一些相当深远的影响。所以，例如，使用平静的绿色或蓝色调可能会激活这种与自然景观的联系，并触发放松反应，并可能减轻压力或创伤相关的症状。然后从荣格的角度来看，ETT中采用的颜色，
they might be chosen based on their archetypal symbolism. For example, like warm colors like red or orange could be utilized to activate this archetype of vitality or energy. And a lot of like chromotherapies that came out in the 70s, they did this, you know, some of them are a little bit crankier than others. Like they would say, like, you know, to be brave before you go into the interview, look at the color blue or something. And generally those have kind of fallen out of favor. If you think that that's what ETT is, it's not. ETT is using very specific frequencies and light directions to get a pretty profound reaction.
它们可能是根据它们的原型象征意义来选择的。例如，像红色或橙色这样的暖色可以用来激活这种活力或能量的原型。很多像70年代出现的色彩疗法，它们做了这个，你知道，其中一些比其他的更古怪。就像他们会说，你知道，在面试前要勇敢，看看蓝色或什么东西。通常这些已经不再流行了。如果你认为这就是ETT，那不是。ETT正在使用非常特定的频率和光线方向来获得相当深远的反应。
Like I said, I watched the color blue turn black in front of me and I'm looking at a piece of paper, but it's looking like a computer screen that can change color. And my brain is like, why, why is this happening? So if you want to see the spectral chart, if you're a therapist in the area, come by the office. I love to like show off how brain spotting and that stuff works. So you can see what it's like and see if you want to get trained in it. But now our brain filters these, this energy that we're talking about into five or, you know, some say six senses. Um, but it's really, you know, just electrical impulses and energy that could be filtered together and, and, and influence each other on the space level before it's processed. So, you know, synesthesia is this intriguing thing. Um, you know, if you're an artist or you're a scientist and it provides this window into
就像我说的，我看着蓝色在我面前变成黑色，我正在看一张纸，但它看起来像一个可以改变颜色的电脑屏幕。我的大脑就像，为什么，为什么会发生这种情况？所以如果你想看光谱图，如果你是该地区的治疗师，来办公室看看。我很乐意展示大脑定位和那些东西是如何工作的。这样你就可以看到它是什么样的，看看你是否想接受培训。但现在我们的大脑将我们正在谈论的这种能量过滤成五种，或者，有人说是六种感官。嗯，但它实际上，你知道，只是电脉冲和能量，可以在处理之前在基础层面上被过滤在一起，并相互影响。所以，你知道，联觉是这种迷人的东西。嗯，你知道，如果你是一位艺术家或科学家，它提供了一个窗口，可以窥见
intricate workings of the brain on a pretty base level. But synesthesia is not the way we think. It's a byproduct of the way we think. And through understanding that, you know, we can understand ourselves and how to heal better and find new ways to kind of trick the brain into releasing all the trauma stored in the body that a trauma therapist is trying to get out. You know, if there is a path to our future models of therapy, I think it's through looking at something like this or understanding the brain in this way. So, you know, all of our senses come from this giant stew pot
大脑在相当基础层面上的复杂运作。但联觉不是我们思考的方式。它是我们思考方式的副产品。通过理解这一点，你知道，我们可以理解我们自己以及如何更好地治愈，并找到新的方法来欺骗大脑，释放身体中储存的所有创伤，这是创伤治疗师试图释放出来的。你知道，如果有一条通往我们未来治疗模式的道路，我认为是通过观察像这样的东西，或者以这种方式理解大脑。所以，你知道，我们所有的感官都来自这个巨大的炖锅
that the brain must filter into specific ingredients afterward. It's not making a stew out of the ingredients. It's pulling ingredients out of a stew. But they've already marinated and they've already influenced each other and the taste of one another is on them. There's some of the bone in the carrot and there's some of the onion in the olive or whatever. That's a gross stew. But whatever. I mean, the stuff is steeped in each other and then we're pulling it out to perceive it. And so I think by looking at that mechanism that what I see influences what I taste, influences what I feel, and influences what I say.
大脑必须在之后将其过滤成特定的成分。它不是用这些成分做炖菜。它是在从炖菜中提取成分。但它们已经腌制过了，它们已经相互影响了，彼此的味道都在它们身上。胡萝卜里有一些骨头，橄榄里有一些洋葱之类的。那是一锅糟糕的炖菜。但无论如何。我的意思是，这些东西浸泡在一起，然后我们把它提取出来去感知它。所以我认为通过观察那个机制，我所看到的会影响我所尝到的，影响我所感受到的，并影响我所说的。
And then, of course, emotion is going to influence cognition. But emotion has already been colored by senses and the body before you even got to mood, and then cognition comes last, and a language-based thought comes last. All this stuff has taken place first. And so if we're going to make a non-cognitive therapy that kind of goes deeper into the brain, this is the way I think about it, and this is kind of an open-ended thought. But accepting all the depth and complexity that's beneath cognition, I think, can help us get a better sense of what makes us human.
然后，当然，情绪会影响认知。但情绪在到达情绪之前就已经被感官和身体着色了，然后认知排在最后，基于语言的思考排在最后。所有这些事情都先发生了。所以如果我们要做一种非认知疗法，深入大脑，这就是我的想法，这是一种开放式的想法。但接受认知之下的所有深度和复杂性，我认为，可以帮助我们更好地理解是什么让我们成为人类。
And it's very late. I'm very tired. So here's a little joke before we go. There's a guy, and he points at a man on the train and he says under his breath to his friend, hey, I heard that guy has synesthesia. The guy with synesthesia turns around and is like, hey, I smelled that. Anyway, have a good night. And if you want to try ETT therapy, come by Taproot. Talk to you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
而且很晚了。我很累。所以在我们走之前讲个小笑话。有一个人，他指着火车上的一个人，低声对他的朋友说，嘿，我听说那个人有联觉。那个有联觉的人转过身来说，嘿，我闻到了。无论如何，祝你晚安。如果你想尝试ETT疗法，来Taproot看看。很快再聊。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。